Transcription: Maite Gistau González
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il était une fois,
dans un pays merveilleux,
une très jolie jeune fille
qui s’appelait Blanche Neige.
Mais la méchante sorcière,
jalouse de la beauté de Blanche Neige,
lui offrit une pomme empoisonnée
qui la plongea dans un sommeil sans fin.
Le corps de la princesse
fut déposé par les sept nains
dans un cercueil de verre
où elle devait rester pour l’éternité.
Mais un jour, un prince, impressionné
par la beauté de la princesse,
posa sur ses lèvres un baiser
qui la ramena à la vie.
Y a-t-il agression sexuelle, oui ou non ?
(Rires)
Vous pouvez lever la main.
Y a-t-il a agression sexuelle ?
Pour qui dans la salle
il y a agression sexuelle ?
D’accord, on va prendre
deux scénarios différents.
Le premier, c’est celui des frères Grimm,
qui a été repris par les studios Disney.
On a une princesse qui est endormie.
Effectivement, dans ce cas de figure,
l’article 121 du Code pénal
punit le fait d’embrasser une femme
pendant son sommeil
puisque le sommeil est un état
de non-conscience.
Mais, la plaignante,
ma cliente, Blanche Neige,
affirme qu’elle était
bel et bien consciente
au moment où le prince est venu
lui déposer ce baiser.
Je me dois de préciser un point.
Une certaine forme de pudeur m’oblige
de parler devant vous de baiser,
mais c’est bien plus qu’un baiser
dont il est question aujourd’hui.
La jupe de la princesse a été relevée.
Là je convoquerais la première -
Une des premières versions
du conte prévoit
que la princesse n’est pas réveillée
à la suite du baiser d’un prince,
mais à la suite de douleurs au ventre
provoquées par des contractions,
neuf mois après la visite de ce dernier.
Donc vous comprenez bien qu’il s’agit
de bien plus qu’un baiser volé
comme essaient de le romantiser
les studios Disney.
Dans notre cas de figure,
on a une princesse qui est consciente,
un prince, et un acte sexuel non consenti.
L’article 190 du Code pénal suisse :
Il faut un moyen de contrainte
pour qu’un acte sexuel non consenti
puisse être défini comme étant un viol.
Je vais peut-être essayer
de vulgariser cette notion.
C’est-à-dire que l’auteur de l’agression
doit avoir contraint
physiquement sa victime
soit par le poids de son corps,
soit en la maintenant collée à un mur
ou par tout autre moyen
de contrainte physique.
Il existe d’autres moyens, mais je
ne parlerai que de la contrainte physique.
Il doit vraiment l’empêcher
de pouvoir résister à l’acte sexuel
qu’il est en train de lui faire subir.
Dans cette situation,
j’ai trois possibilités.
Numéro 1 : la fuite.
Mais je suis en sandales,
je ne cours pas très vite,
donc je vais rester là.
Numéro 2 :
C’est la contre-attaque.
Mais bon, vous êtes quand même 200,
donc on ne va pas
se battre là concrètement,
La troisième possibilité c’est que,
en fait, je vais rester là,
et je vais m’immobiliser devant vous,
et je ne vais rien dire,
et je vais attendre que ça passe,
et ça peut être très long.
Ce dernier état,
que j’ai essayé de mettre en scène
très bizarrement,
on appelle ça l’état de sidération.
On peut métaphoriquement imaginer
que ce sont les mêmes effets
qu’une pomme empoisonnée qui
aurait été croquée par Blanche-Neige.
L’effet de sidération,
c’est lorsqu’on est totalement paralysé,
on a la voix qui déraille,
on est tellement choqué de la situation
qu’on annihile
tous nos systèmes de défense.
Ce qui fait qu’on est devant vous
et qu’on attend que ça passe.
C’est un traumatisme, une réaction en fait
qui est très courante chez les princesses
victimes de violence sexuelle.
Parce que je suis avocate et que je
travaille dans un cabinet spécialisé
dans la défense de femmes victimes
de violence sexuelle,
je peux vous dire que l’état de sidération
est une réaction très courante
chez les victimes.
Et si on reprend la définition du viol
comme je l’ai exposée en début,
où il faut un moyen de contrainte,
qu’en est-il lorsque
la princesse est sidérée ?
Puisque, par définition,
c’est un corps inerte.
Elle n’oppose aucune résistance
à une hypothétique contrainte physique
qui n’a pas lieu puisque l’agresseur
n’a pas besoin de contraindre sa victime
pour arriver à ses fins.
Donc on a un impensé,
on a un vide juridique
et pour moi, c’est une situation injuste.
Il y a justement en ce moment
dans notre Parlement suisse
des débats sur
la question de l’introduction
de la notion de consentement dans la loi.
Comme vous l’avez vu,
c’était la notion de contrainte
qui était au cœur
de la définition de viol.
Aujourd’hui, des mouvements
humanistes, féministes,
militent pour l’introduction
de la notion de consentement
pour justement permettre
à ces princesses sidérées
de pouvoir obtenir justice
dans nos palais.
Il y a un deuxième problème, à mon sens,
au fait de ne pas introduire
la notion de consentement
dans la définition de viol.
C’est la place que l’on donne
aux femmes dans notre société.
La loi, les contes, sont les miroirs,
les beaux miroirs de nos sociétés.
Donc on peut y lire également
les stéréotypes et les manières de penser
et de lire cette histoire commune que
nous vivons ensemble, notre humanité.
Je vais l’expliquer en prenant l’exemple
d’une autre infraction du Code pénal.
La violation de domicile.
La violation de domicile, le bien
juridique protégé, c’est la liberté.
Pour ce qui est du viol, le bien juridique
protégé, c’est la liberté sexuelle.
Le bien juridique protégé
est un ensemble de valeurs
qui justifient le fait
qu’on criminalise certains comportements.
Donc, je reprends la violation
de domicile.
Imaginons que vous êtes chez vous.
Voilà, vous regardez la télé,
vous faites absolument ce que vous voulez.
Quelqu’un vient sonner à votre porte.
Vous vous êtes endormi devant la télé,
donc vous ne répondez pas à la porte.
Logiquement, la personne, qu’est-ce
qu’elle fait ? Elle ne rentre pas.
Elle repart chez elle, fait ce
qu’elle veut, mais ne rentre pas.
Maintenant, vous êtes chez vous.
Vous ne vous êtes pas endormi
parce que le match se passe bien.
La Suisse mène.
Et qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
La personne sonne à votre porte.
Mais bon, c’est les tirs au but.
Vous n'avez absolument pas du tout
envie d'ouvrir la porte.
Est-ce que là, la personne
est autorisée à rentrer ?
Non, toujours pas.
Parce que chez vous, c’est votre propriété
et vous avez le droit
de mettre une barrière.
Et cette barrière, c’est votre porte
et cette porte,
c’est la notion de consentement.
Donc là, si je reviens du coup
à l’infraction de viol,
pourquoi est-ce qu’on part du principe
qu’une princesse, par définition,
par nature, serait à disposition
pour un acte sexuel ?
Sauf si elle oppose une résistance
et que de cette résistance,
on aura un moyen de contrainte
de la part du prince.
Vraiment, je ne comprends pas.
Enfin, un petit peu quand même.
Je pense que ça dit beaucoup aussi,
comme je vous l’ai dit,
de la place de la femme dans la société
et également de ce qu’est une loi.
Une loi, c’est la transmission
d’une histoire,
c’est un héritage et notre histoire -
Là, on se situe en Europe,
on est à Genève.
Par exemple, il y a moins de 300 ans,
on continuait à brûler des sorcières
parce qu'on estimait que les procès
en sorcellerie étaient justifiés.
En réalité, c’était une violence
faite à des femmes
parce qu’elles étaient des femmes.
Le corps des femmes,
de tout temps, a été réifié.
Réifier, ça veut dire
réduire à l’état de chose.
Et quand on réduit quelqu’un à l’état
de chose, on le déshumanise.
Et c’est une manière aussi
de penser un rapport de force.
Si une femme est à disposition,
est un objet de plaisir
et non pas un sujet,
ça veut dire qu’on s’imagine
être dans un rapport de domination
vis-à-vis d’elle.
Pour moi, introduire
la notion de consentement dans la loi,
c’est finalement réhabiliter les femmes
dans leur humanité,
c’est prévoir d’éradiquer cette injustice
qui vivent les princesses sidérées
et c’est aussi envoyer un signal fort
aux générations futures,
aux princesses de demain,
en leur disant qu’elles ont
le droit de poser des limites,
qu’elles ont le droit
de poser des barrières
et que c’est au prince également
d’apprendre à gérer cette frustration
de ne pas pouvoir entrer dans la pièce
qui ne leur est pas autorisée.
J'ai voulu amener ce sujet devant vous
aujourd'hui parce qu'il est important,
parce qu’il est débattu
et que ça implique tout le monde
puisque depuis que le monde est monde,
les êtres humains
se reproduisent de la même manière.
Criminaliser des comportements sexuels,
ce n’est pas anodin.
Ça implique beaucoup.
Ça peut faire peur, je comprends.
C’est pour ça que, à mon sens,
il faut qu’on ait
un débat apaisé de société là-dessus,
qu’on s’entende,
qu’on est un dénominateur commun
sur ce qu’est le consentement.
Est-ce que c’est uniquement verbal ?
Ou ça peut-être non gestuel ?
Est-ce que le consentement
se donne et se reprend ?
Est-ce que le consentement à un acte donné
vaut pour toute autre pratique ?
Ce sont vraiment des discussions
qu’il faut ramener à un niveau citoyen
pour le bien-être de notre société
et de notre vivre ensemble.
Je dis ça aussi parce qu’on a
une scène que je vous ai décrite,
en liminaire de cet exposé,
où le prince s’imagine embrasser
sa bien-aimée, l’amour de sa vie,
et la princesse,
elle dit subir un crime sexuel.
Donc il y a vraiment quiproquo.
Je pense qu’il y a un vrai enjeu
à essayer de combler ce vide, cet impensé.
J’estime que, en tant que personnes
discriminées par cette loi, les femmes,
nous avons voix au chapitre
et qu’il est important d’entendre
les personnes concernées :
des milieux féministes,
comme j’ai pu le dire, mais également
des associations qui militent
pour les droits humains.
Également, des centres d’aide
aux victimes se sont prononcés
sur la réforme législative qui a eu lieu
pour demander à ce que soit introduite
dans la définition du viol
la notion de consentement
pour que tout acte
non consenti soit un viol.
Point.
Je ne vais pas faire semblant que ça
n’implique pas des questions
quant à l’applicabilité
d’une telle disposition,
mais disons que ces questions
ne sont pas insurmontables.
Elles ont par ailleurs été surmontées
dans d’autres législations européennes
qui ont adapté leur droit pénal sexuel.
Comme je vous l'ai dit, je suis avocate.
Avocat, ça vient du latin advocatus,
qui veut dire porter la voix.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai voulu porter la voix
de personnes qui sont privées
de pouvoir le faire.
Notamment les personnes sidérées,
mais en fait tout un chacun qui
fait partie d’une minorité discriminée,
pour qu’on puisse également
faire partie de l’histoire commune
qu’on est en train de vivre.
Je citerai un philosophe
que j’apprécie énormément,
un philosophe palestinien
qui s’appelle Edward Saïd,
qui posait la question suivante :
a-t-on le droit
de faire partie de la narration ?
Les contes, les lois,
par qui sont-elles écrites ?
C’est une question qu’il faut
qu’on puisse se poser
pour comprendre pourquoi
est-ce qu’on peut trouver
des discriminations
à l’intérieur de nos dispositions.
Je conclurai également en vous disant
que j’ai parlé d’hommes contre des femmes,
pas par misandrie, parce que moi
aussi j'ai des amis hommes.
Je n’ai rien contre eux,
mais tout simplement
parce que la loi le prévoit comme ça.
La loi actuelle suisse qui réprime le viol
prévoit que seule une femme
puisse être victime d’un viol.
Jamais un homme sera considéré
comme étant victime d’un viol.
Je vous l’ai dit, les lois
sont porteuses de stéréotypes.
À teneur du droit actuel,
le prince est acquitté
et la princesse Blanche Neige
se taraudera longtemps en se disant :
« J’aurais dû me défendre, j’aurais dû
dire quelque chose, j’aurais dû partir. »
Finalement, je vous laisse
avec cette pensée.
J'ai essayé d'allumer un point
d'interrogation aujourd'hui devant vous
pour vous laisser sur cette question :
finalement, pensez-vous vraiment
que qui ne dit mot consent ?
(Applaudissements)